[Music]
all right
raise your hand if you consider yourself
a pessimist
always looking for the negative always
always you
i'm pretty negative how about an
optimist
and it doesn't have to be like you're
one or the other
just like which one i'm pretty
optimistic you're both
yep okay i'm pessimistically optimistic
complete
you're optimistically pessimistic no
pessimistically optimist
okay i feel like anytime something bad
happens i still don't like get upset at
that so
like motorcycle accident i'm like that's
pretty funny what do you call it when
you're
positive when you're supposed to be
negative and then you're negative when
you're supposed to be positive
crazy with the sociopath wrong
that's cold exactly dude
couldn't have said it better i don't
think it's not about like not getting
upset
like getting upset but [ __ ] man i'm sure
there's
got to be a reason for this it's like a
little bit more like that
still optimistic yeah like it's not like
ah
man that was a fun car accident i don't
go there you know
oh i go there damn that's powerful
i mean isn't that like what a lot of
comedian brains do is like you see the
funny and the
bad a lot of comedians are so
pessimistic they are
and negative they just point out the
terrible and then people laugh at it and
they're like
why are you laughing oh let me tell you
more terrible [ __ ]
right some of them are like that damn
all right well
this new um what no nothing keep going
what okay tell me no i just i
feel self-conscious it was i just didn't
know where we were
i'm just making fun of you but you keep
going it's okay enjoying the moment i
was enjoying the company please continue
with the article
please let me be a pessimist about this
i'm just kidding okay so
there's this the study that has found
that people who are strongly pessimistic
about the future
are at greater risk of dying earlier
than those who are not pessimistic so
they actually die
on average two years
sooner than optimus oh i'm super
optimistic
i have great feelings about the future
so that's different okay what about the
now [ __ ] pessimistic
i think that's everyone right now 2020
sucks
not for me but yeah oh what the [ __ ]
i was trying to have your back bro well
to be fair
i'm optimistic about 2020 us being here
in like august and like
i hope the worst has passed us so i'm
optimistic
about the rest of the year true yep
yeah so i think everything's gonna be
good
hey help me [ __ ] we kept thinking the
worst was over
and then some other [ __ ] [ __ ] happens
and you're like
this is the optimism this is optimism
crazier it also gets funnier
that's true so [ __ ] it
yeah so they're saying that they found
that people who were strongly
pessimistic about
the future were more likely to die
earlier from cardiovascular diseases and
other causes of death
but not from cancer oh i mean i get it
like they don't live long enough to get
cancer like you hear about those spouses
like when what their partner dies and
they get really sad
and then they have a heart attack oh so
it seems like it really affects you like
your emotions really affect your heart
[ __ ] it
no your emotions affect you physically
period everywhere yeah
it does that's why if you have none
you're good
yeah the healthiest people around are
sociopaths
no but yeah so they're saying that
optimism scores
uh on the other hand so people who were
optimistic
they did not show a significant
relationship with death
either positive or negative so they're
just like they're gonna
they're just they're gonna die when they
die and it's fine like it doesn't make
it doesn't prolong their life expectancy
by being optimistic it's just that by
being pessimistic
it actually shortens your life does that
make sense yeah that's the first way to
look at it
because you're worrying all the [ __ ]
time you know how stressful it is to
worry
it's [ __ ] stressful like physically
stressful
like and to say i don't care and being
like just walking
in the street with your eyes closed it's
way more relaxing
than opening them up you know what i
mean sometimes
way safer too right variables are
interesting no it's safer
word no no no no no no not say it's more
dangerous
but it's it's more relaxing try crossing
the street with your eyes closed
and you hear hahaha but you don't hear
the car you don't see the cars coming
so you're just you're just relaxed
because in that very moment that very
second
nothing has touched you so you're okay
in that second yeah
and they move around you see around you
you hear haha
and you're like i'm glad i don't have to
see this [ __ ]
and you get to the other side and you go
oh [ __ ]
that that happened around me oh [ __ ]
that's like little grandma on mulan
with the lucky cricket she's the cutest
but is there is there in between
optimism pessimism it's like a neutral
zone or is it like if you are not
dude i think this is basically it's
relative to who's talking
well so to answer your question though
they are saying that optimism and
pessimism are
not direct opposites so you can
then why the [ __ ] do they compare it as
a pro and con
okay so specifically for this study
they're saying that
the they ended up studying people back
in 1993 to 1995.
there were good old days there was data
collected from almost three
three thousand participants who
completed this like questionnaire
and they were aged over 50 and again
this was
between 1993 and 1995 okay the world is
changed
they're saying that the participants
have they were invited to agree or
disagree with the number of statements
including
positive statements such as i'm always
optimistic about my future or negative
statements such as
if something can go go wrong for me it
will and so
oh yeah people that feel they're unlucky
they die early
yeah so then those questions and that
that data from back then
they were then crossed cross-checked
with the australian national death index
back in october of 2017 to find out how
many people had died
and their cause of death so they found
that more than 1 000 participants had
died out of those 3 000
participants and so then they started
looking into the correlation between
optimism and pessimism
and specific diseases such as
cardiovascular disease heart problems
yeah heart problems yep and so
they saw they found that like previous
studies they would put
optimism and pessimism on one scale why
they well they ended up they're saying
that they use
two separate scales to measure pessimism
and optimism and their association with
all causes of death
and that's how they discovered that
while strong pessimism was linked with
earlier death
those who scored highly on the optimism
scale did not have a greater
greater than average life expectancy so
that's that's how they were to
figure that out um but then they were
they
were just looking into the fact that
pessimism
does seem to be linked somehow to
heart problems and it obviously like
what we were saying emotions
physically affect your society so you're
saying that there's some sort of concept
of like
an average life expectancy those who are
pessimistic maybe
have a two year less cut off those who
are optimistic
maybe have average here yeah that it
doesn't improve the lifestyle
how does that math work out because if
you just combine the two wouldn't the
average of those two just be down there
then
well that's why i guess they're saying
the study they're not comparing
specifically optimism and pessimism but
rather they're
comparing its relativity to average life
expectancy that's what i'm saying i'm
like if you split
any group into two right and then if you
have two numbers
you can't have the top number be average
but also have a bottom number
because then the average of that is a
middle number but that's if the groups
are mutually exclusive
i think they're saying it's inclusive so
the optimism could also just be in the
average
so the so it's not like so who's in the
positive
the uh the optimistic people duh i don't
know that's average
yeah i think it's an average human
expense expectancy
and then they separate uh optimus and
pessimist and then see what if the
based off of human life expectancy
averages
if those two fit where they fit in that
scale
yeah so the way that they concluded this
here is this one paragraph it says
understanding that our long-term health
can be influenced by whether we're
a cup half full or cup half empty kind
of person might be the prompt we need
to try to change the way we face the
world and try to reduce negativity even
in really difficult circumstances
i think if you want your life to suck
it's going to suck ass
what is that called cognitive bias or me
yeah because it's like you see what you
want yeah you see what you're looking
for same with manifesting
your destiny or whatever right like if
you're constantly looking
at how life sucks it becomes real
such as the universal law of attraction
yeah
but that's just because um you have a
con that confirmation bias going on yes
i feel like optimists though are more
likely to die from
unnatural causes because famous last
words are always this is fine
i'll probably be okay and they'll like
do something real crazy and then die
really because actually heard the
opposite professionals would be like
that's too crazy that's dangerous i'll
still die of cardiovascular disease
i'd rather work in that you know they're
just like that's too crazy for me i'm
gonna stay over there and
the other guy is like everything's gonna
be all right i just
walk across the street blind in 95 that
was like extremists that die from
optimistic beliefs
i know right because there's only 3 000
people
for senior citizens over 50 that were
being tested in 93 to 95 like it's a
very overall messaging though is really
cool right i think all they're really
trying to tell you is like
hey man don't worry be happy i think
that's literally all they want you to
post
yeah they could have just written some
bob marley lyrics right
why are you wasting people's time from
93 to 95 the golden years
why have you guys seen free solo yeah on
netflix the documentary
what is it about it's about the guy that
climbed uh is it el capitan yeah half
dome
a half dome with no bungee cords with
nothing with no attachment
yeah so if you fall you're you fall
you're dead yeah and
many people have attempted it many
people are are gone
they're all they're optimistically like
let's try it
and then so there's a guy one of the
guys that was trying it as a precursor
then they showed footage of him like
he's all happy he's like i'm gonna try
it but i'm gonna have a safety
he has a little squirrel suit on so he's
climbing it so he has no attachments but
if he
falls off he can pull it and land to
safety somehow so he
he climbs half of it this full falls off
pulls his squirrel suit
ah what a close call he's gonna try it
again
and then the next frame and the document
it's like r.i.p
i was like oh [ __ ] he's gone you can't
frame it like
he's just gone he's one of the guys are
gone and then the next the next frame is
like
it says 90 percent of people that have
uh try to
climb um half dome and the fades out
are all dead oh my god it was just crazy
i was like
[ __ ] dude were they all positive people
though they could be
or they were like optimistically making
the choice to go there and then
pessimistic when they were on the wall
you know
the free solo guy specifically they did
a brain scan of his mind
of his brain and you know the part that
like tells us to not [ __ ] play with
fire because these are the consequences
that part of his brain was either
underdeveloped or missing
so like it's the same as like a
psychopath almost where he's like
where people's normal sense of danger
it's like it's like not there for him
yeah it takes a lot of stimulation i got
a huge part of that in my brain right
here the fear part
just kidding oh i was just clarifying i
fear
none i fear everything that's why
respect off your none shameless plug
hashtag oh got it man
for the pessimist they should have a
mask that says i scared
everybody
you